فصل جديد في المسار الشائك للعلاقات
الامريكيه الايرانيه هذه المره تتجه
الامور نحو تفاهم هادئ عبر الوسيط العماني
عنوان هذا التفاهم المال مقابل السجناء
فيما الهدف الاكثر الحاحا للامريكيين
وتجنب كارثه في الموضوع النووي
الطرفان لم يلتقيا لوجه بحسب مجموعه من
الصحف الامريكيه لكن الوسيط العماني يتوقع
نتيجه سريعه لا سيما فيما يتعلق بالسجناء
الامريكيين المحتجزين في ايران استطيع
القول انهم قريبون المساله تنحصر في امور
فنيه هم بحاجه الى وضع اطار زمني بشان
كيفيه تنسيق ذلك مكاسب الاتفاق تبدو
مناسبه للطرفين في الظرف الحالي امريكا
تستعد مواطنيها السجناء الذين تحولوا الى
نقطه التوتر الاساسيه بين البلدين ايران
تحصل على مليارات الدولارات المجمده خصوصا
في مصارف كوريا الجنوبيه ويعود الملف
النووي الى مسار التهدئه بعد خروج عمليات
التخصيب عن السيطره الاتفاق المتوقع ياتي
في اطار مشهد اقليمي متغير هذا المشهد
يهيمن عليه من جهه الاتفاق السعودي
الايراني برعايه صينيه ومن جهه اخرى مخاوف
اسرائيل المستمره
وتاكيد رئيس الوزراء بنيامين نتنياهو عدم
الالتزام باي اتفاق بين واشنطن وطهران
لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات